hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to introduce the parity operator
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics the parity operator
is the operator that describes a
reflection about the origin
for example when applied to a wave
function it reflects it from
r to minus r for this reason it is also
called the space
inversion operator the parity operator
is extremely useful
particularly in problems with inversion
symmetry in which reflecting the system
about the origin doesn't change its
state such problems include simple
examples such as the infinite square
well
or more interesting cases such as the
quantum harmonic oscillator or the
hydrogen atom
to make it even more exciting the
interactions between
fundamental particles such as the
electromagnetic interaction
or the strong nuclear force are
symmetric under parity the only
exception
is the weak nuclear force which does
break parity so
to become familiar with this topic today
we'll define the parity operator and
explore how it acts on quantum states
there is a companion video in which we
explore the
interplay between the parity operator
and other operators and i also recommend
you check it out to complete your
understanding of the parity operator
let's go the easiest way to define the
parity operator is by considering its
action on position eigenstates
remember that the position eigenstates
are defined by the eigenvalue equation
of the position operator
although i'm using the same labels for
operators and their eigenvalues and
eigenstate which can be very convenient
we have to be very clear about what each
symbol represents
so to make sure that we understand every
symbol in this expression let's start
with
r hat it is the position operator
the next symbol the vector r is the
position
eigenvalue and the ket r
is the position eigenstate associated
with the eigenvalue r
so we need to make sure that we don't
mix this up
we're now ready to define the parity
operator
we label it with the symbol pi hat and
define it by its action on the position
eigenstates
by setting this equal to the eigenstate
minus r
as simple as this now to understand what
the parity operator is doing let's throw
a set of cartesian coordinate axis
if the vector r here is the position
eigenvalue of state
r then the application of the parity
operator
generates a new state minus r whose
eigenvalue is the vector minus r
obtained by a reflection about the
origin of coordinates
for this reason the parity operator can
also be called the space inversion
operator
with this definition it is very
important that we don't confuse the ket
minus r
with the negative of the cat r the first
is the
eigenstate of the position operator
associated with the position eigenvalue
minus r
for the second this part here is the
eigenstate of the position operator
associated with the eigenvalue r
and all we're doing is multiplying the
ket by the scalar -1 here
this is a subtle but essential
difference to be able to confidently
work with the parity operator
so make sure you're happy with it
the definition of the parity operator by
its action on the position eigen states
up here
allows us to then deduce its action on
arbitrary states
all we need to do is to expand the state
of interest in the basis of the position
eigen states
and then we can act with the parity
operator on those
as an example to start with let's
consider the action of the parity
operator on a momentum eigen state p
from the video on wave functions which
you can find link in the description
we know how to expand this momentum
eigen state in the position basis
the expansion is given by a fourier
transform
we can now move the parity operator
inside the integral
and doing so we get this expression here
this is now the action of pi on the
position eigen state
so we get this
it is now convenient to change variables
to r prime
equal to minus r with this change the
integral becomes this
two things to note here first i have
conveniently rearranged the exponent
so that the minus sign comes up with the
p here
and second we should in principle have d
minus r prime here
but as the integral is over all space
then the integral over d minus r prime
is in fact equal to the integral of d r
prime and i've just directly written the
r prime
this expression is now simply the
fourier transform of the state with
momentum minus p
so we can write it as the ket minus p
what this all means is that the action
of the parity operator on a momentum
eigenstate
gives another momentum eigenstate with
an eigenvalue reflected
about the origin this strategy is
general
to figure out the action of the parity
operator on a general state
we first need to write out the state in
the position basis and then we can act
with the parity operator on the
individual position icon states as we
just did in this example
the reason i used this example to start
with is because it shows that the parity
operator acts on both position
and momentum eigenstates in the same way
we simply reflect both quantities about
the origin
let's recap we've defined the parity
operator by its action
on the eigenstate of the position
operator as i'm showing up here
from this definition we can then in
principle reduce its action on arbitrary
states
and we've exemplified this with the
moment eigenstates getting this result
up here
what i want to do now is to look at the
general case of an arbitrary state
psi the first step is to expand it in
the position representation
as usual the expansion coefficients psi
of r are given by the bracket
r psi and remember that these psi of r
are what we call the wave function of
the system
now let's consider the state that we
obtain by acting with the parity
operator on psi
expanding psi in the position basis as
we just did
we can then move pi inside the integral
and we get this
using the action of the piety operator
on the position basis states
we end up with this
at this point it is convenient to see
what this new state pi
psi looks like in the position
representation
to do so we can insert this expression
we just obtained
in here and we get this
we can now move the bra here and we end
up with this
the position basis is orthonormal so we
get
psi of minus r so what does this mean
if we start with the wave function psi
of r and we apply the parity operator
then we end up with the wave function
psi of minus r
this means that the pi t operator
reflects the wave function about the
origin
we could of course follow the same
procedure to find that if we start with
the momentum wave function
and we act with the parity operator on
it
then we obtain the momentum wave
function at minus p
in conclusion for a general state psi we
can deduce the action of the parity
operator
by simply calculating the wave function
of the state and then reflecting it
about the origin
now that we've defined the parity
operator and figured out how it acts on
general states through its actual wave
functions
the next step is to look at some of its
fundamental properties
the first is that it is involutory this
means that it is equal to its inverse
to see this consider the action of the
parity operator squared
on an arbitrary position i can state we
can expand pi
squared like this the definition of the
priority operator
gives the state minus r here and we get
this
applying the definition of the parity
operator again we end up with the state
r
comparing the initial expression with
the final one
we see that pi squared is equal to the
identity operator
and this confirms that the parity
operator is its own inverse
we could actually have guessed this
property by just remembering that the
parity operator describes spatial
inversion
if we reflect r about the origin of the
coordinate system
and then reflect it again we get back
where we started
the second property of the parity
operator is that it is hermitian
which means that it is equal to its
adjoint
to see this consider first the defining
equation of the parity operator
next we build the corresponding
expression in the joule space
remembering that to do so we need to
turn all kids into brass and all
operators into their adjoints
let's now calculate the matrix element
of the parity operator between two
position eigen states r
prime and r we can use this expression
in state space
to rewrite this one here and we get the
bracket
r prime minus r as the position basis is
orthonormal
this gives delta r prime minus minus
r which simplifies to delta r prime plus
r we can now calculate the corresponding
matrix element for the adjoint of the
parity operator
using the expression in the joule space
here we can rewrite this one here
and we get the bracket minus r prime r
this again gives a delta function and as
the delta function is an even function
it is equal to this comparing these two
expressions
we see that the matrix elements between
any pair of position based states are
equal
implying that pi is equal to pi dagger
confirming that the parity operator is
hermitian
the next property is that the parity
operator is unitary
which means that its inverse is equal to
its adjoint
this follows trivially from the fact
that the parity operator is both
involuntary
and her mission
i now want to look at the eigenvalues
and eigenstates of the parity operator
let's start by writing down the
eigenvalue equation
where this here is the eigenvalue and
this here is the associated eigenstate
to figure out what these are let's start
by writing down the eigenstate
we can trivially write this as the
identity operator acting on lambda
using the fact that pi squared is equal
to the identity we get this
we can now reorganize this expression
using the eigenvalue equation here we
get lambda pi lambda
and using the eigenvalue equation here
again we get lambda squared
lambda comparing the initial expression
with the final one we see that lambda
squared equals one
which in turn means that lambda is equal
to plus or minus
before we proceed we could actually have
guessed this result from the fact that
the parity operator is hermitian
and unitary this is because the
eigenvalues of a unitary operator are
numbers of magnitude 1
and the eigenvalues of a hermitian
operator are real numbers which combined
only leaves plus one and minus one as
the possible eigenvalues of an operator
that is both hermitian
and unitary moving forward for the
eigenvalue plus one
we'll label the corresponding eigenstate
with psi plus
and we call sargent state an even state
similarly for the eigenvalue -1
we'll label the corresponding eigenstate
with psi minus
and we'll call it an odd state using
these definitions the eigenvalue
equation of the parity operator
becomes this more generally we will say
that even
andoth states are states of definite
parity
you'll immediately see that the position
and momentum eigenstates that we used to
define the parity operator do not
satisfy the eigenvalue equation so they
aren't parity eigenstates
however parity eigenstates feature in
many quantum systems
examples include the energy eigenstate
of the harmonic oscillator or of the
hydrogen atom
to understand why parity higher states
are so common you should check out the
video on
even and old operators
we showed earlier that a very powerful
way of determining the action of the
parity operator on a general state
was to study the action on the wave
functions associated with that state
so we'll now investigate what even and
odd states look like in terms of wave
functions
let's consider the defining equation of
an even state
if we project this state onto the
position basis to obtain the
corresponding wave functions we get this
we showed earlier that the piety
operator leads to a wave function
reflected about the origin
and it is simply the wave function psi
plus of r
putting this together we see that even
eigenstates are represented by
even wave functions similarly we can
consider an odd state
projecting onto the position basis gives
this
this is psi minus of minus r and this is
psi minus of
r showing that for all eigenstates
we have odd wave functions
the final idea i want to discuss in this
video is that we can write
any arbitrary state as a combination of
an even
and a node state before we can see that
though we first need to introduce
two projection operators we call the
first p
plus and it is equal to one half times
the identity operator
plus the parity operator and the second
one
is p minus and it is equal to one half
times the identity operator
minus the parity operator remember from
the vdm projection operators that their
defining property is that they are
either impotent
which means that they are equal to their
square that means that to demonstrate
that p
plus and p minus are indeed projection
operators we need to calculate their
square
so let's start with p plus squared
spelling out the definition of p
plus we get this we can then carry out
the multiplication to get
these four terms we know that the square
of the parity operator
equals the identity so we simply get
this
as expected this is p plus
this confirms that p plus is a
projection operator
following a similar strategy we would
find that p minus is also a then potent
so it is also projection operator
okay now we know that p plus and p minus
are projection operators
the next thing is to check that they
project to orthogonal subspaces
to do this we consider the product p
plus p minus
inserting their definitions we get this
multiplying through we again get four
terms
this is again equal to the identity so
we end up with zero
this confirms that the two operators
project onto orthogonal subspaces
and the final feature of the projection
operators we need is that they project
onto complementary subspaces which
remember means that their projections
span the full state space
to see this consider the sum of p plus
and p minus
inserting the definitions yet again we
get this
and combining them we obtain the
identity confirming that they project
onto complementary subspaces
we can now use these two projection
operators to see how we can write
any state psi as the sum of the two
states one even
and one odd they relies on realizing
that these projection operators project
onto eigenstate of the parity operator
to see this consider the projection p
plus on an arbitrary state psi
acting with pi on this state we can
expand the projection operator in terms
of the parity operator
multiplying through we obtain this
we know that pi squared equals the
identity and we get this
this here is now the definition of p
plus
so we get p plus psi
this shows that acting with the parity
operator on the state
p plus psi gives the state p plus psi
again
this means that p plus psi is an
eigenstate of the piety operator with
eigenvalue plus one
so we can write it as psi plus because
it is an even state
we can repeat the same exercise with the
state obtained by acting with the
projector p minus
and psi acting with the piety operator
on this state
we would find that it gives minus the
same state
this means that p minus psi is an
eigenstate of the piety operator with
eigenvalue -1
so we can write it as psi minus because
it is an
odd state overall and that's anticipated
this shows that the projection operator
b plus acting on an arbitrary state
generates new state that is
even and the projection operator p minus
acting on an arbitrary state generates a
new state
that is odd the final step is to show
that we can write an arbitrary state psi
as a sum over psi plus and psi minus
to do that we can trivially insert the
identity here
we just showed that we can expand the
identity as the sum over the two
projection operators
multiplying through gives this and it is
simply psi
plus this is psi minus
so we can write an arbitrary state psi
as the sum over two states
one even and one odd
at this point this result may appear
like a curiosity but in reality it is
very useful because even a node state
are related to something called
selection rules
you can find all the details in the
corresponding video linked in the
description
but in short what this means is that the
matrix elements of certain operators
calculated between even and dot states
vanish
which is an extremely helpful result
that simplifies the maths in many
problems for example when we study
optical absorption
to recap the parity operator is defined
by its action
on the position eigenstates reflecting
them about the origin
it then follows that its action on the
momentum eigenstates is analogous
in terms of wave functions the
application of the piety operator
turns psi of r into psi of minus r
the key properties of the piety operator
are that first
it's involutory second it's hermitian
and third from the first two it follows
that it's unitary
the eigenvalues of the piety operator
are plus one
with the corresponding states called
even or minus one
with the corresponding eigen states
called odd
finally we have also found that we can
always write an arbitrary state psi
at the superposition of an even and an
odd state
we're now familiar with the parity
operator and how it acts on quantum
states
although today's description has been
rather abstract the ideas we've
discussed such as
even anode states play a key role in
many quantum problems
and the action of the parity operator on
quantum states
is just part of the story don't forget
to check the video on even and odd
operators where we discuss the interplay
between the parity operator
and general operators and as always if
you like the video
please subscribe